Recently we had the video about gallium and radio
activity, and several of you in your comments,
and one viewer culminates in an email pointed out that I had
completely missed a really good connection between gallium and
plutonium.
And that gallium was really important for making atom bombs.
This came as quite a surprise to me because if you look at the shelves behind
me, there are quite a few books on atom bombs,
mostly on the history,
but I'd never even realized that gallium was important.
And it's only important in the bombs that contain plutonium,
such as the one called fat man that was tragically dropped on the city of
Nagasaki.
10 58, the morning of August 9th,
the bomb was exploded above the city and in the towering mushroom,
Japan could rate its doom.
And the problem is related to the way that atom bombs work
and the way that an atom bomb works is that one
atom of plutonium is hit by a neutron.
It splits into two releasing energy,
and it produces two neutrons,
each of which go on to react or to split other
atoms of plutonium.
So you'll get to chain reaction and the explosion just
builds up and up and up.
[Inaudible].
No the two problems that you have, if you're building an atom bomb,
the first one is that you have to have enough plutonium so
that if a neutron comes out of the first plutonium atom,
it will hit another plutonium atom before it escapes from your lamp
plutonium.
The second problem is you mustn't have too much plutonium or the
spontaneous radioactive decay could start the bomb exploding
before you're ready.
So you have to have a very precise mass of plutonium.
And one of the ways that they get round this,
or they got round this when they were device in this boom was to have a sphere
of plutonium,
which had in the middle two elements beryllium and
polonium, which when you mix them together gives you lots of neutrons,
but the beryllium and polonium was separate in the middle.
And the idea was that the whole of the plutonium was surrounded by
explosive at the right moment,
all of the explosive would go off and the ball of plutonium would be compressed.
It would get denser, the plutonium atoms closer together.
So it was harder for the, to escape. And at the same moment,
the beryllium and polonium would be mixed up together.
And a big number of neutrons would be released to set the thing off. Now,
the key point was that the sphere of
plutonium had to be absolutely round because otherwise,
when you try to compress it, if it wasn't round,
it would squash into the wrong shape and wouldn't get dense.
And the difficulty is that pure plutonium is very
difficult to make into a shape.
The technique they used was called hot pressing so that you take
heated mold and press it at, I think,
400 degrees centigrade w with pure plutonium,
you get the so-called alpha phase, which when you take the mold apart,
begins to flake off and is not suitable.
It was realized that you could mix the plutonium with a small amount of
another element,
which would change the arrangement of the atoms and the metals so-called
different phase instead of the alpha phase so-called Delta phase,
which was slightly less dense and much easier to mold or
to hot press. They began by trying Allie minium.
But the problem with Alli minium was that it could itself become
radioactive as plutonium atoms, decayed,
and the radioactive aluminium started giving off neutrons,
which could have caused the whole thing to go off prematurely. In the end,
they went down the periodic table from aluminum minium to gallium
and gallium worked really well. You just needed a small amount of gallium,
bit more than 3%.
And that was enough to fabricate the sphere in the way you wanted.
Mean like cooking professors. It's a bit like putting an ingredient, like,
you know, an egg or something into your cake just to help get the mixture,
right?
Yes, I suppose so. And, um,
it's not so much that it's bonding them.
Togethers arranging them in a better form of packing by light your egg.
Professor,
would the gallium then stay in the plutonium for the life of the bond?
Yes, the garlic just stays there. And in fact,
because the density is slightly less, and of course,
as the sphere gets bigger, you can get more on the outside.
You can actually get a bit more plutonium in your bomb and it still
be safe or least safe until you let it off.
The other thing is that plutonium itself can oxidize react
with air.
So you have to give it to coating on the outside to stop it reacting with
air. And on the first bomb,
the one that was tested in New Mexico,
they put a layer of silver,
which wasn't very satisfactory and subsequently they put the layer of the
metal nickel and then the bomb has a whole filter
multilayer of different metals,
and then the explosive to put the whole thing together.
And one of the books that I've got it's called atom bombs has quite a
nice picture inside showing how this is put together.
But the reason for having this ball is this bowl is almost
exactly the size 3.62 inches in
diameter 9.2 centimeters of
the core of the Batman bomb.
So it's really not very big.
And when the bomb actually went off,
the amount of plutonium that split and gave the energy
was only one gram,
the ball of plutonium weighed over six kilos.
So just a tiny fraction of that actually caused the explosion.
And presumably the rest of the plutonium was blown all over the place.
Like gallium was an important ingredient,
but it was an important ingredient for the manufacturing of the bowl.
Not for any part of the detonation or explosion or anything.
And according to a website,
I looked at called FH two's about nuclear weapons.
Gallium is still used for making volatile nuclear
weapons professor.
Do you think all these books you're buying and websites you're looking at are
going to get you on some kind of watch list? I hope not,
But I think that they,
the history of the project of the atom bomb is
extremely interesting,
not only for the physics and the chemistry that was involved,
but the deep moral question that has always worried me that if
I had been a scientist during the second world war,
would I have worked on nuclear weapons.